d'accord la corde attend jeu je passe
mon tour à toi ma fille peut-être que je
triche mais en tout cas moi mon bac j'ai
eu du premier coup
ça n'a rien à voir pour parler j'ai
horreur comme toi de tee shirts et tout
mais c'est pas grave asie joujou mais
nous ne t'aimons barbare un trinôme ok
je t'avertis y tout de suite on se fout
complètement notamment ce que ça veut
dire tu alors liliane dans la série
jérôme des mots veilleux de nous à
trouver typhon mais tu sais que ça
existe c'est revient aussi subi une
saillie des lettres comme ça tu veux
avoir plus de points de ton mari et je
vais le dernier mais jouant fou monsieur
comme je triche j'hésite attrape tout le
monde comparé à la basse à celle
avantages du tee shirt sur les joueurs
honnêtes alors alexandre ton nouveau mot
c'est quoi bioshock ou y
oui je suis mauvaise humeur oui
parfaitement je suis mauvais oeil humain
hier si vous continuez à m'emmerder
changer tout envoyer balader 1 et
battait d'ailleurs je faire maintenant à
lyon
voilà qui fait joli le scrabble dimanche
va à la pêche
[Applaudissements]
m